you talked about the potential if it's  appropriate of pardoning some of the  january 6th yes  lindsey graham said a couple days later  he thinks that's inappropriate  what do you think well lindsey graham's  wrong  i mean lindsay's a nice guy but he's in  rhino  lindsay's wrong  look  this is really the kind of bottom of the  barrel  uh  disloyal trump there's no loyalty for  trump his best friends again to the  extent he has real friends and i don't  know if he does trump's relationships  with people including his own family are  very very strange his friends are  immediately enemies if they say just one  wrong thing  graham is just the latest victim here  trump going on to talk about how many of  the writers  are not even guilty  he says that they're patriots some of  them they're not guilty of crimes  and says lindsey graham  doesn't know what the hell he's talking  about